[Music]
yeah let me do the math we've got $1,000
that's roughly around 770 pounds British
pounds a food pack is 60 pounds so let's
divide it okay we've got about 13
families 13 families let's roughly less
effectively nice family less times that
by five that's 65 people that you know
this problem has fit well you have the
opportunity to but is that just for one
day no that's for the reminder I'm gonna
do is one of the times that by 30 you
see when it comes to this stuff brother
and sisters when it comes to business we
calculate how much money am I gonna be
how much I'm gonna make you my
investment how much should I put it how
much you like it okay but what about
your hereafter were long what about you
hereafter well us want to say it's
nothing but perfect this brother who
gave $1,000 is going to feed one
thousand nine hundred and fifty
individuals is that it no it's not you
know why because they were just gonna
eat and go sleep they're gonna pray and
they don't have the energy to pray and
they're gonna have energy to do a bath a
multiband and you're gonna get a reward
every single one I think a person hears
what I'm singing and ignores this has to
leave a question they're hot and I'm
sure every single one of you guys have
mercy in your heart bond sisters I'm
going to keep it long there's the mat
there's the money and the link is at the
link below Salah donate mouth humor
relief foundation we are on the ground
making it happen with our own hands
okay guys this girl's got a special
message for all the donors in the UK
thank you